this is a production of Cornell
University to be here today
four years or so before every Tiger
development an actor as well so I
thought it would be usable with a lot of
a lot of studies over the years it's any
different components of a system and its
kind of couple to then stand back people
look at the whole system interact so I
thought a lot of relations would be a
complexity erections that would be an
interest we Apple first you're all
familiar with domestic apples in general
but they actually have the center of
origin mountain Kazakhstan that turns on
mountains didn't this is actually a
picture of Apple force in in Kazakhstan
where the primary trees are and so the
commercial varieties came from there it
turns out that there seems to be a
rather narrow gene pool so that our
commercial varieties are relatively
close to the wild types and there's been
very little of any breeding for water
relations
I've been primarily for yield and
quality and sustainable bearing but not
for a water relation so we're really
thinking of the plant as wild land and
so
the climate they're in there and it's
hard to get good data from this area but
it appears to be an area with some dry
periods in this number but not period
where it seems to be a moderate climate
with with dry periods in the summer
I personally leave size and shape
suggests this type of climate so we
think the physiology way of looking at
at water relations was suggested by Neal
Turner to look at perform at or looking
at a relationship so the first one is
drought avoidance or escape a lot of
times you think of the ephemeral growing
in the desert doesn't weigh in the
stadium but if the plant is able to grow
in very cool season conditions and
that's a way of weeding the midsummer
condition another one is if they do have
to grow through the summer you can try
to maintain of the water potential at
the high met I let them so even though
there is just you tolerate the drought
by maintaining high water plant and
that's usually through reduction of
water loss the cuticles stomata behavior
reduction of radiation for the natural
leaf area of sorts of things and another
aspect of maintaining the water is to
maintain the water uptake so either
increase fruit density or finding more
water and in or increase in conductivity
conductivity to to give the water the
water potential maintaining and of
course if it has to tolerate a more
severe drought then there's the
mechanism such as automatic adjustment
to maintain trigger
that cushion elasticity in size
something that really hasn't been looked
at with Apple so get into that part so
let's look at some of these ways of
looking at them and their implications
for practical for the avoidance issues
both happen of Apple there tends to be
two types of shoots although they're not
strictly separated and that is that you
know mature plant we have these very
short shoots that produce of rosette of
leaves that's called the their bubble
Spurs and the there's preformed leaves
within that bud and it's also the place
that where the fruit flowers and fruit
are born and so these performance come
out very quickly in the spring and
there's a single lateral shoots off of
that that can you've got mortared
leaf area typically dia tends to produce
short shoot and so you get the rosette
with another short shoot on top of it
and that makes guys for complex that you
see on the right so these come out very
quickly in the spring and they can
develop the very significant canopy and
so at the bottom here you can see a
cornfield in late May I don't know
that's actually typical or they just
planted it but in late May this was a
field that ended up being corn and then
on the right you can see the canopy of
apples is is really going that low
developed they begin growing fairly
early mid-april
so their conditions are quite cool to
run 12 and 4 Celsius and by by about 40
days 30 days or so
perhaps your butt break they big boom by
that time you have something in the
neighborhood of 20 to 30 percent of the
week area that you're going to have
maybe 40 you have 250 percent of the
light intercept so they have a very
rapid canopy development they are able
to develop a lot of that canopy and
productivity before we have significant
drop stress to mention also the
temperature so when you have a very long
growing season like in New Zealand or or
their way they they may have fallen but
they can have very long growing seasons
and the leaves will stay on if your
weather stays stays good Nick and stay
on for a long time so later they can be
very productive as well so the other
type of shoot are the extension students
which are the ones that can grow out the
winter note so the leaves are spaced out
these can grow basically all season long
and determinant shoot although equal set
of mine but it's the weather conditions
and then the weather conditions allow
and it's good water status it will
continue to grow far into the season
very often here we will see them stopped
growing
basically by but they could grow some
cases I've seen other Dibley they were
actually growing into them so use that
flexibility but they can also stop very
very quickly and they may not only grow
just
you centimetres if you have the very
drive early part of the season it's a
flexible response in terms of reducing
potential knee area at least not
necessarily exercising these what are
the other things that they mentioned is
reduction in water loss the dimension
cuticle and apples we have a very affect
you at all so that that's active that
the variable one obvious that's the
model behavior and this is something
that's fairly fairly unique without pain
then is if you look at the
photosynthesis versus belief conductance
and this is in in field trees normal
summer conditions you don't see that
type of hyperbolic curve that you might
expect with the opening of domains in
photosynthesis we almost always find a
very linear relationship between them
the snow makes seem to be very highly
coupled to the photosynthesis and so we
get a linear relationship and the other
thing we see is in a dumb open anymore
then the photosynthesis continues right
and so in most cases you'll see the
stomata conductors open more and more
focus and this is light goes out and so
you'll see the will tail off on the on
the right side we don't estimate those
publications around 23% and they just
don't roll it up excessively under
normal field conditions now this data
actually is I get it
this is the actual data from three
different sets of measurements the pink
squares are other controls they're
healthy water the green triangles are
from consider water stress and the blue
symbols are from branches that we burn
on the branch to speak back in a vision
and shut down photosynthesis and yet
they all fall in exactly the same
progression so we've learned that over
the years that that in the field we see
a very very strong coupling between them
the photosynthesis and the smaller
behavior which is permanent you've done
that weed and the field almost never
seemed very my Hou chu-u conditions what
that's not true oh but I should an
intimate and the field what happens is
that because it's basically linear you
get a you tend to have a very constant
yru sufficiency assuming you know at any
pressure deficit because the you're
opening up the snow mates at the same
rate synthesis is going out so what are
you sufficiency across that ranges it's
really a quite constant we're in many
cases there's nobody's open up too much
and the photosynthesis doesn't increase
you'll see a decline I am and so apples
have a very very good water use
efficiency now I now just to reviewed
everything I said apples have an
interesting characteristic and that is
that they if you look at the response to
BB D you see two different types of
responses under very low stress
conditions so in many cases potted trees
or growing in very very low stress
conditions and things like that you'll
find that the stomata conductance at
very humid conditions low BB D can go up
very high this domain can open up very
much
but in the field we see the blue markers
down below where they it will drop off
at the high vvd but they really don't
respond to that that's a low BP be in
high humidity so they don't open up
nearly as much as they normally would
these days are actually from the same
branch on the same tree but three days
apart if there is stress they will
behave like the blue markers where they
they don't respond to humidity after
three days of very humid overcast
drizzly conditions then the in the black
markers show that they can open up
pretty widely under most stress and then
about two three days later
under normal conditions again they have
got that so it's not a set response it's
a very dynamic response and so have some
thoughts on why that is so the some
unresponsive BB is quite unusual what we
think they were interpreting that is it
basically the Green Line just shows that
there's a limit due to the humidity on
the opening of the domains perhaps a
fillable transpiration that's
illuminating the opening line but in the
video we have a second response and that
is a limitation imposed by the coupling
of the photosynthesis so like I showed
earlier the if we hurdle the huge and
the photosynthesis is dropped by 80%
this domain is closed so under those
conditions where you have low
photosynthesis and could be due to like
a very little code get accumulation of
hydrates the photosynthesis goes down
then you get almost no response at all
so
in many cases you know we may see very
young responsibly but we think there's
two interacting this will now another
thing is the reduction of each area
apples don't really didn't really excise
of if they don't drop the leaves like in
most cases what it does is it stops
producing new leaves and I you know stop
producing new leaves and retain old
leaves there's some real advantages in
that you're not constantly having to
build new leaves so the respiration
rates of apple trees we've used mold
canopy balloons in the middle of summer
the respiration on a sunny day if it
fixed a hundred grams of carbohydrates
or co2 and I get may only respire five
very very low respiration value because
they're not producing a lot of new new
tissue but to make that work those
always have to be able to be productive
for many many months and that is another
unusual thing that Apple is that so this
this plot shows the spur leaves we
mentioned earlier they come out
beginning of the season they came out
and they were first measured and at the
end of April this is in Washington State
and basically their photosynthesis rate
didn't change until the middle of
October and if you go out at this time
of year even to these walking shoes at
least every two days so they have
different ages they all will give the
same photosynthesis rate so they have a
very very slow turnover they can stay in
almost complete dark two weeks take off
the shades and they'll still be green
after a couple hours of acclamation
light
so the leaves on the interior don't
really fall off so it's a interesting
combination between the water relations
in okay in terms of the radiation
absorbed relationship the leaf area as I
mentioned that leaves it doesn't
broccolis with one of the
characteristics and it does do is it the
exterior leaves that are exposed to
highlight fold and if they're exposed to
highlight and additional job stress they
fold even more and I've seen some where
the Argent almost touched they folded up
so much what this does is it reduces the
turkey load on that individual lead but
of course those leaves that are having
the full Sun normally so that they're
really not short of energy so they can
still photosynthesize it pretty much the
maximum rate but what it does is it
allows light to be inter trading into
the canopy where the interior leaves are
flatter so the lower the light land of
the leaf mix and of course they're going
to low light so the additional height
yet is used very efficient so it does
seem that it it should be increasing
what are you sufficiency of the enemy so
not necessarily reducing the total
length intersection so Apple tends to
tend to be the type is not so
conservative because it retains those
old leaves keep some of Trump and so and
it doesn't broadly so doesn't really
reduce its water loss dramatically as
any other plant with the shutdown and
drop the leaves but it it sort of toughs
out the moderate grounds so
I know reported it said in really drying
conditions apples are considered very
drop sensitive because they can't make
it through two or three months where
other things like great will be very low
just shut down drop leaves and we'll get
through the drought but in shorter
droughts they can stay more productive
and so that seems to be their big
national can the other aspect that
mentioned was making this water I take
my increase route connectivity or using
the resistance of that root system well
Apple root systems have a relatively
high rolling resistance and flattened
they need to adjust that in the roots
study from her student Fred Davies where
we had potted apple trees for three year
old trees that we kept in a very humid
glass house so very little member
benanna conditions and we put half of
them out in a gravel area were much
hotter prior and and after several weeks
that we then we noticed that when we
took water potential readings of the
leaves and in those two conditions they
had the same value even though they were
under dramatically different conditions
so we brought them together and the
resistance of the top grooves and we
found that the times didn't really
change there a garlic resistance but the
root changed by about sixty percent so
when it was out in the dry conditions
resistance decrease allowing a higher
conductivity or though the water and
actually maintained the water potential
at the same value I think this is when I
talk to colleagues in Israel hi Reuben
all over wet water tree in the middle
in the summer for them they all intended
to give about the same water potentials
even though they're living in quite
traumatic this is a quite strong effect
anatomically we are visually we could
not see the difference it wasn't a
matter of on growing a lot of young life
so we don't know exactly in terms of
another way of maintaining sugar is
osmotic adjustment and this is something
that apples do we've found it two and a
half negative Pascal's or 25 bars just
in in a dry season it takes time it
takes another week to get 83 years like
that so it's kind of a long response but
let me start looking at it we found it
you look at my potential up a chute that
mature leaves basically I'll have a
quite low osmotic potential but this
your tips have a much higher that's not
a got potential and over the season we
found that those chute tips did not
change in their water potential so this
makes the extension shoots that are
growing those tips don't automatically
adjust so they respond directly to the
change in the water potential with a
Ryan condition however the mature leaves
do automatically addressed and so this
allows them to maintain turgor over the
season and so you can see the mature
leaves are responding to the conditions
where the grown shoot tips
basically are not at all so that is
abusive work before the older leaves and
keeps
keeps the turgor and the water status of
the older dudes better so they can be
productive first a minute on them being
able to be productive on lost time so so
it's a mix of coherent picture damn this
is a study from from England where they
looked at trees and they found that on
the osmotic the solid lines are
irrigated - non irrigated monstrous and
you can see the osmotic potentials were
literally high early and went down from
about fifteen or sixteen thirty five
extreme so about a twenty five justement
there well the water potential was it's
gradually going down also the different
end is the trigger and you can see that
basically over the season that the
automatic adjustment was able to contain
the trigger both for the inebriated ones
that went up and down but also for the
stressed ones so the mic adjustment is a
is I think a very usable tool for the
plant that has this type of we've
mentioned the roots and the getting
their hydraulic conductivity but apple
roots especially in on earth orchards
they're not growing on the seedlings in
the big root systems are vultures are
are using the worth stocks that keep the
plants maybe two meters or sometimes
less in height and so they they have
root systems that can see there's a
picture can actually extend quite a ways
but but they're not intensive so a lot
of studies have been done that find that
the movement density of apples varies
from zero but up to
25 or so on an average I've seen one
flag seeing some values of a lot like 3
where they've got some data from corner
there's other plants even higher day
they can go up to 30 centimeters per
cubic centimeter soil so the
implications of this is one is it if you
have one root growing up an apple and
you have 100 groups a corner or a
thousand roots of grass we're getting
the same volume the grass is going to
win and we see that if you have if you
have a grass between the road you don't
get a lot of that over it's roaming in
that grass they tend to grow in the
other areas and so that has a new
patient for a practical growing and
Briggs words are very similar they will
try to avoid the competition grasses and
colors now because of the high hydraulic
conductivity there's a very strong
relationship between wheat water
potential laughs and the transpiration
so the the intercept at 0 transpiration
that basically on the plant so that can
go up and down a few bars but the
strongest effect is the transpiration
because of that and on the right you can
see there's a quite a strong diurnal
pattern in the water potential of the
apple trees and they'll go down to this
is older data from Landsberg about 16 to
20 bars and it's a well water it's not a
that's not a problem for them because if
there was not an adjustment so we have
this very strong diurnal pattern the
other implication
the root link density and this was
calculated by Landsberg Jones from the
earner is that as the soil dries out the
rhizosphere resistance will tend to go
up more rapidly with low room link
density basically if you look at the
estimates for old water use in the field
estimates are something like you know we
have at 80 maybe even 90% of grass uses
so the percent of eto and so you haven't
the apple trees are using almost the
same amount of water as their grandmas
but they're taking it up with maybe one
100 or 500 this is mini roots so you've
got very few roots they have to take up
a lot of water and so in the middle of
the day when they have a very high
transpiration rate of their calculations
suggest that there should be a
significant localized drawing around the
roots and I was actually some
information data from Spain where they
around 150 percent of et and they they
got increased growth and they have they
had less negative in day one of the ten
trees then if they just put on a hundred
percent of B team at night before and
though in the writers who depended only
on the the hydraulic conductivity of
soils would place that part so so we
think because of that movement density
that we're having a significant
rhizosphere increase in resistance in
the middle of the day and so it makes up
these estimations you modeling that
other component being variable as well
as the plant itself
now the
another mention was some maintenance of
water uptake by increased density or
death the results of this has been very
really variable in some cases there has
been a little bit of increase as this
job shows that the bottom line is checks
and the other two are different stress
levels similar response when they did to
have them somewhat less roots of the
very top layers and then in the middle
zone they had so got more roots and a
lower to make much difference so they
didn't seem to be pushing deeper but
they did test alone but other studies
have found basically no response so that
doesn't seem to be a major major
mechanism for Apple okay I talked about
some of the the practical implications
things like to me water use for
irrigation or they might affect those
things also how we actually go hearing
those we did work with students on Leon
now these does he only do a summer
coming and that is when and typically
around the 1st of August or so you go
out if you have a lot of canopy the
after through the red ones need direct
sunlight to get a good red color and so
there may be too much shade and so the
growers will go in and out long shoots
with their own way and they quite a bit
of leaf area actually estimated with
although some growers they were doing
some other severe or something they
actually removed between 350 area and to
be able to fruit as well as supposed to
possible and so we did take a look at
that using
we'll canopy gas exchange systems that
use for several studies and we found
that the canopy transpiration was
reduced by by that summer pruning pretty
much unfortunate for those the amount of
big barrier removed not a wonder one the
years and then after we did the summer
pruning we looked at these stem water
potentials the first columns on the left
were just before the summer pruning nice
sunny day and the skimmer potential see
they were basically the same and then
later in the day after the summer
pruning we did it again and found about
a three bar adjustment of redemption in
the in their level distress slight
difference so you can see that there was
a difference caused by advance and about
a week later spill there so in some ways
this make you the opportunity to to try
to reduce somewhat the stress on the on
the fruit it's kind of a compromise
though if you have a heavy crop you
don't want to take up too much area or
you want a good size but if you have a
lower crop it's not limited by the
variances producing this may be an
opportunity to be game but usually not
used for that purpose but we have seen
in the in many cases one or two to
understand how much water being used to
diet irrigation for our growers and in
some ways we found that it seemed like
we were irrigating or than we did and so
the real question of how do you estimate
the water use apples in our
like that because we're not in
California Washington where where they
develop the business and of course it's
hard to estimate that from soil moisture
because of the variable distributions of
the cover crops so we wanted to try to
understand how to do that and of course
the general approach using use of that
equation and for agricultural crops
usually the approach is to have a
reference plant faster and use the model
of MIT for that reference and then your
crop is as a fraction of that
so the that's the coefficient or kc is
the fraction it works okay in places
like california and it works okay when
we have days that are like California
but it doesn't seem to work very well in
in New York and so basically shockingly
a grass is not a very good model now so
we thought what we need to take a look
at this a little bit more detail
we found that we're over irrigating in
using that provision approach from arid
zones now we are over your gating in
cool years and the turns out that Ichigo
is very very strongly and then radiation
you look at the eto and begins radiation
is 93 something like that so it doesn't
have a very strong response to
temperature humidity but in cases where
we would have very cool humid conditions
but sunny we get a high eto but we get
lower water use and so we realize that
with tall brush structures that we
needed to look into how are they
responding to the fire house that there
was some theoretical study that
suggested the coefficients that are
developing arid zones may not work
correctly in humans homes so if you look
at an orchard and with the grass in
between you can see that for the grass
below there's a heavy boundary layer
especially in orchards and vineyards
where you have a windbreak every three
meters or so so what happens is that you
have a boundary layer that basically
when the humidity comes out of the plant
and tomato event it basically tracks
that humidity so the snow is open the
beef even from them so they basically
cancel each other out and that's why
there's pretty much just that's not the
case with the apple tree because of the
rough structure there's very very good
air flow around the around the leaves so
if any humidity comes out of leave is
immediately mix with the bulk air so
then these two model opening makes a
difference and the radiation makes it is
the energy occurs and the inherent BBD
in the bulk air exiting difference so
the two systems are being controlled by
a different combination factors so we
wanted to actually go take a look but we
wanted to be able to measure it directly
we use sap flow gauges but we didn't
trust them to make all the estimations
of wound factors so our student danila
agrimony did a study with using sap
flows ages from we installed them and
then we calibrated them with the whole
canopy guest for several days and then
remove the gas exchange fevers and
[Music]
calibrating xi o we recalibrated later
in season so this way we could get a
really direct measurement accurate
measurement without disturbing
so we did that we found this is the
action the actual prop coefficient is a
fraction of eto during this type of a
season it should be something like
constant 0.8 you can see that's not
really not true there are some days
appeared that we're not dry and nice and
there were some days that were cool and
he'd been that's funny so they had high
eto but low end up trees so in this case
we could see that we really couldn't use
the coefficients from arid climates and
so we developed our own apple specific
penalty operations and so for Fanta
changed the for the boundary layer and
other factors but we did use this unique
stomata conductance weird in terms of
conductors versus the amount of demand
epp it goes down with the very dry
conditions but it plants out and the
more moderate human conditions so we
could not make the measured data model
until we put that relationship in there
and then we did get a so this model then
was put on to the website in the climate
center with art and peed-on and
calculates water balance for the growers
using the data from the new global
weather stations
he's always we mentioned that water
status strongly affects many factors
obviously we use for synthesis but it
also reduces as you both rate and as we
have mined from the the lack of
adjustment the the shoe tips the growth
rate is pretty much
reduced by stress case we use stem wire
potential as the best integrated
measurement and then also root growth
rate through tends to have a little bit
of what should be a stress so these have
a very strong effect watch this and as
this growth canopy and of the food so
really how we deal with that variability
there we talk about because there's a
strong transpiration effect and we shown
the soil variation and can cause some
variation there but the weather patterns
have a big effect on the transpiration
so it means if there's temporal
variation going on very dynamic and
depending on the winter our crazy
weather you can imagine a variable it is
spatial also any orchards you're not in
the most uniform soil some are but the
may be on hills or you have in areas
where you get spatial variation soils
and then there's a lot of physiologic
development so trying to model all that
to estimate what the actual water
suppress is in the plant is something
that's really very difficult and it's
obviously best just right
and so since to mention the water status
of the plant depends on so many of these
factors all these parameters and
treatments so a lot of availability
where the roots are water is but the
sort of water content versus water
potential these curves looks like so
there's so many different things why not
just an injury and so of course we we
have done that for many many years using
the scroll under pressure chamber or
called the pressure bond it's manual
that's accurate you get good
but it's very slow very limited data
because the name of nature there can be
significant career area and it can lead
to operate a team if you can see lumbar
or four five and take take a hit so in
this this case you know after doing this
from two leaders or thirty of the time I
said well we've got to come up with some
we got to somehow get this pressure bump
thing into a some type of sensor that we
could stick inside the plan and get
continuous reading that we can sit back
so contacted the age group in
engineering who's working on physics of
water plants and we thought well the
conventional Scott litter has a very
good basic physical principle and so if
we could just turn that big one into a
little children that we could make a
micro version of that to be able to
insert it into the trunk or using the
soil and then be able to get in at my
hand so that was the this is aim and the
name okay remember was a grad student he
was the first one to work with us on a
joint horticultural can engineering
student and he was followed up that tree
event Lady Gaga who developed it further
as a practical tool and see you jus
Apple and also in the corn so we're
interested in seeing how that works
so the the center itself is a sandwich
they say there's a quarter is a quarter
in there but tiny I ate Anna leaders and
in there so pressure transducer to
measure the change in pressure and then
there's an exchange surface that you can
see on the right which is a silicon with
denim denim Peter Tatchell Forge and
because of that we have a very very
large range normal tens you don't learn
about one bar or less hours we'll go
that one go through them but a hundred
is sort of learn so we get a huge range
and then the chip is mounted into a
cylindrical probe you can see there next
with the chip on the side and the this
shows a little bit a bit easier in the
top left you can see their children
Educare we drill a hole with a guide and
a special and Bill bit to give a flat
work this is a prototype of we hold it
to the tree but there's the developer
and some nice ways of installing it and
so this is studies from a couple years
ago when we had a drought and you can
see that the sensor is in the apple tree
that's that's before all the insulation
we have to do an installation over that
but on a cloudy day you can see the red
line is the radiation and the stem water
potential is offered a little bit by the
response time of the sensor that a lot
seems to be a lot by the tree himself
there's a students and so you can see
the type of data they gathered it does
correlate well with the pressure bottom
except occasionally we'll get a early
morning they'll be kind of a spike sap
flow agency that we and so they just
might do to achieve
changes in temperature so we have to we
do have a temperature sensor so we
actually have that now this is the study
that Cu has done with an apple trees and
you can see the diagonal pattern blue
line and then the pressure bond values
box so it really is is looking like
dreams coming true and we do to get this
actually available to growers no big its
own it's a micro electromechanical
system games would you it's not
something that most history and
companies do the people that do it are
interested in this application so I was
a small startup and I hope Yago is late
on that even but they're making a lot of
really good progress I'm getting that
available under the first sales that
would be next year on it so we're
getting pretty excited about it and of
course I like to acknowledge got a lot
of the people especially that terms
Robinson for 35 years now there's a lot
of work would be radiation or taken to
the field and technicians graduate
students is not put them all out there
and some of the different sources of
funding but I really have to make a
pitch for hatch yes
basic state plans because nobody wants
to pay for water relations studies in
this kind of planner they even say a new
study learning relations I said well in
California on the irrigate they never
have because it's always the other water
they need here if we don't have rain
stress so we have a lot more conscious
than they do what places they are you
know so okay so I think over the years
it's extremely interesting but there's
actually useful things this type of
study
thank you through danger
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu